[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the lifelong
podcast are you joking no i'm just so
fixated
on the word you want to be a lifelong
podcast yeah man hey we're gonna do it
do this forever welcome to air biscuits
the
podcast where two lifelong best friends
talk about life for a long time
i'm link i'm rhett you added best again
which i
i don't i don't have any problem anytime
you add best because we are best friends
it makes yeah it feels good i just the
reason i don't add it
is because it feels like it messes up
like the flow a little bit but it is
true
so you might as well say it i did say it
and i'm not taking it back and
i don't need your approval i'm red i'm
link's best friend
and uh this week at the rental table of
dim lighting we're gonna be talking
about
my camping trip your solo
excursion into
i mean i mean i have all these pictures
in my mind
of this bearded tall man in the
loincloth
out in the deserts of nevada pretty much
got it right
um except trying to accept
and we you know we had this whole build
up about
how this was for you and it's not
necessarily for me
or for anyone listening so we need we
need to get into all that
but i hope you can tell us enough
because
i'll tell you enough i got i've been
picturing a lot
and i needed to i need i need you might
be building things up too much
how do you want to do this slowly
methodically
no um i have a lot to say
okay about my experience i do want to
say
up front and we talked about you know
the build up to this was like
th this is about me kind of going out
and having this time
with myself it's about self-discovery
and i
was very especially because my mission
was to not having to have a mission
my agenda was to have no agenda right
and my
sort of approach was to uh
separate the trip from it
needing to be translated into an
entertaining story right because
again that just kind of brings the focus
back onto me in a negative way not in
like an enriching way but in a selfish
hey here's what i got to say here's what
i'm going to bring back from the
mountaintop kind of way
and i didn't want that uh i tried really
hard the entire time i was out there to
make sure that
i'm not making decisions or writing
things down
with an audience in mind because i live
my life in a lot of ways with an
audience in mind it's part of the job
right
and this whole trip was not about the
audience it was about me
so i am going to
i'm going to talk more about i'm going
to talk about some of the fun and
practical
things that happen some of the you know
would i am going to talk about
one update that i have based on the
conversation that we had the argument
podcast we had
a couple episodes again the sports
sportsmanship the sportsmanship
i thought you're such a good sportsman i
insisted that you were a great sportsman
and i didn't believe i was a good
sportsman when i when i
come in my competitive when i uh tried
to prove to you over the course of an
hour that you were competitive
uh we're going to talk about an updated
perspective that i have on that
uh but i will say up top that
what i would say are some very
significant
uh emotional and dare i
say spiritual things occurred
that i will not be talking about okay
yeah i respect that
because if you went into those things
then i would be like
well that's that really hits then hits
it on the head of what you said
you didn't want to do so you're going to
talk around the only reason
the only reason i'm saying that is
because again that was i went into the
desert
um for i would say
for spiritual reasons yeah i mean for
emotional slash spiritual reasons and
it was an incredibly enriching
incredibly fruitful time
from the very beginning i thought that i
was going to have to you know wait
until day three or something but even
the first morning of camping
it was just a very enriching time but
again i almost feel like
it sells it short to talk about it it
also makes it about me trying to
i it's not it's not about me having
anything to share and any wisdom or
anything like that it was just something
that happened with me
uh that i might talk about at some point
in my life or on this
podcast i don't know but that's not what
this is going to be about i get it i get
it
i think i think that's a good job i
don't want to cheapen anything that
happened by making it into a
podcast can i can i cheapen it yeah do
you know cheapen it i mean i
no but seriously i there are some things
on my mind i'll just throw out some
questions now that you can answer at
any point you want okay i think because
i did find myself thinking especially in
the first
two nights of me camping um
i found myself thinking about i wonder
what rhett's situation is because
like i said i was out christian out
there were were camping
in the most isolated situations i've
ever been in
right i mean because even when i did my
solo trip to slab city
there was like someone renting out this
abandoned rv to me and i had contact
with people and
i was on the edge of a city i was never
this alone and i was assuming you were
that alone
and i knew that last time and again you
wrote about it in the book of
mythicality
you got really scared that one night
that's one thing that i found myself
like
just being swallowed by the darkness
because it was you know and the stars
and did your wife be in there making you
less scared oh
of course and then i'm like because what
i would tell christy i was like
i wonder what res doing she was like why
do you keep talking about rhett
it's like because he doesn't have you or
jesse there
like i have you i'm like you know it's
i think that's my main question is like
how scared did i get scared but you
don't have to
you don't have to start there and then
i'm curious about the hot springs and
like i was concerned that like you
didn't
i knew you were gonna you wanted to be
at a hot spring alone
yeah and i i don't know how easy that is
so i was
but i was hopeful for you so so that was
the so again
the idea of the trip just from a
practical standpoint was
uh i've got my old fj cruiser
2007 fj cruiser with it's only got a
hundred thousand miles on it but i
recently just got some work on it
took it in to get there that's an
understatement based on the price tag
so i basically bought a new car by
restoring
this car did i technically own half of
that car at one point uh yeah but i
bought it from you
okay and you bought the scion from me
that's that i got this i got the fj
cruiser you got the size but it wasn't
the same amount of money
uh was it yeah don't worry about it go
ahead
no actually we probably we paid more for
the scion than i paid for the fj cruiser
um but i'm kind of glad i got the fj
cruiser
yeah anyway so i i just put this a new
rooftop tent on the fj cruiser and again
like i said i got a bunch of work done
because when i took it
and i was like i'm taking this thing
across the country they're like well
you need new blank blank blank blank
blank blank blank
lots of money went into this thing don't
want to get stranded but it's basically
like
do i want to continue to use this
vehicle as my off-roading
vehicle indefinitely or do i want to get
like the new bronco or something like
that
when it comes out and so i decided to
throw the money at the old car
which is less than a new car anyway um
i mean i spent weeks getting ready for
this trip and like i've got these
like drawers not like the cool nicely
installed uh
you know you can get like it's not a
sprinter van i mean but you can get
custom-made pull-out roll-out drawers
that go in the back of suvs
and they're made specifically for the
different suvs because i had all this
you know all these tools and all this
stuff to
be able to survive on my own
indefinitely or for six days
um but i ended up just getting like 25
dollar
uh plastic sterilite
drawers that faced each other in the
back but i this is where we're starting
you're talking about plastic drawers
i put everything in there to be ready
and i was super excited about this
rooftop tent and the idea being that you
literally
can drive anywhere yeah that's public
land or
national forest land and as long as you
find a spot
off of the road you can just camp right
yeah and most
and we call it dispersed camping and
there's you know oh there's a firing
somebody's been here and i use the same
app that you did the ioverlander app
early recommendation i guess because
that you can find some places that
people have been whatever
so the idea was to loosely
follow this route that would take me to
some hot springs that had been
recommended to me but also some that i
kind of just found
on another app there's a hot springs app
that shows you every thermal
springs in the entire united states
okay and the temperature and a little
bit of information but basically it
shows you the coordinates and then you
can kind of just navigate to it and
check it out and there's a lot of them
in california and nevada
turns out but in the day before my
two days before the trip um
all the national forests in california
closed down
yeah because of so many fires uh and
they're like smoke
the forests are closed no camping no
hiking you can't go in there
and i'm like well damn it my route is
taking me up through all these
national forests and what am i going to
do am i going to just go somewhere else
and
i was like screw it i'll just go that
way and
first of all there's the blm land the
bureau of land management we talked
about in your episode
which surrounds mostly it's like
corridors of interstates and stuff like
that
it's kind of before you get further off
the highway into national forest
and that wasn't closed it had all the
fire restrictions in place you could
have a campfire but you could have a
stove
so i head up north and
i just had this loose idea that i wasn't
gonna make it i wasn't gonna make myself
have to make it to a hot spring on the
first day
because i felt like making it to a hot
spring on the first
day was too accomplishment-oriented
you know what i'm saying like having to
get to a place and do the thing that is
a thing
just go and then if you don't then you
fail right take it a little bit slow
yeah and so i stopped at a place
you may have seen this sign before going
up to mammoth alabama hills
first of all when i sent the text from
my uh
satellite device to my wife i said i'm
camping in
the alabama hills and she was like how
the hell did you get to alabama
in five hours but that's just the name
of them they're in california
and it's it's like um you know joshua
tree has
these crazy rock formations and they're
just giant boulders stacked on top of
each other that have you know kind of
everything's eroded away
yeah and they're these crazy like almost
car to small house
size rocks that are stacked on top of
each other that are super easy to climb
same exact material same exact process
that happened in joshua tree
has happened in this little place right
right outside of lone pine
okay lone pine california is like
if you believe there's the like the uh
film
museum there because they've shot so
many things in lone pine because
the mountains can look like uh
the himalayas they so they've shot the
mountains in
california right there next to lone pine
as the himalayas in all kinds of movies
oh and if you've got like mount whitney
and all that yeah and if you go by
you know because we go to mammoth ski
and as you take that trip a lot of times
you're like man that looks like the
himalayas
to somebody who doesn't know what the
himalayas look like right
and uh but there's just so many movies
that have been shot there and this
alabama hills a bunch of movies have
been shot there because it has like a
martian kind of uh you know just sort of
this
different sort of landscape sort of feel
to it anyway so
i get there and it was one of those
remote but not completely remote like
the park is you know it's a few
square miles or whatever but you're just
a bunch of dirt roads that go
up to these big boulders and there'll be
a fire ring there
and i'm like driving around like ah
somebody's there i'm gonna keep going
oh somebody's at this one and eventually
i found one that somebody wasn't at and
it was like a giant uh
sort of cul-de-sac with this big rock
and then this rock wall kind of u-shaped
rock wall that had like a name on the
map it was like for like rock climbers
i think it was called like the loaf or
something like that
it's like seven eight stories tall of
these
giant rocks and so i was like okay i'm
here like i can
like if the person at the campsite next
to me turns their car on
i can hear that and if they yell i can
hear that but i can't see them because
they're over this
like rock sort of that's good let's not
lie
that's what you want and i can like play
music in my campsite and they can't
really hear like i have to be pretty
loud
yeah so i was like this is a it turns
out that that is the sweet spot as
i will get to when you are too close to
somebody or when you're
too far away from somebody you get a
whole different problem huh which i did
for two nights so i'll talk about that
but um that first day
i like park the car get the rooftop tent
opened up
get everything set up put my little
table out feeling good and then i just
i'm gonna climb these rocks why not
right and i just start go i go up to the
rocks and i just first of all i'm
thinking about snakes constantly
it's it's amazing how the older you get
the more you think about all the things
that could go wrong
and when i was actually rocking you
getting you getting a
you getting an animal from a snake well
that's how it works and when i was a
child you know as a kid growing up we're
just like swimming in the cave of the
river stepping on water markets it's not
thinking about
anything and i'm like walking along and
like
clapping i'm like they can hear clapping
right stamping really hard
if somebody was seeing like what is he
trying to think they hear heat no they
hear
vibrations so i'm trying to make
vibrations because i know it's going to
be a rattlesnake probably if i see one
yeah and i'm like are they still out
this time of year i think so it's still
pretty hot
but eventually i climb up i get to
the almost freaking top of this thing
and there's a little place to pass
through
and i pass through and come into this
other valley of there was
nothing but these giant rocks
and i was like this is wonderful what
this is like a cathedral
and i just sat down on a rock you passed
through to the other side and i just
sat there and i was like this is going
to be a good trip
but it doesn't have to be because i
don't want an agenda
did you have water i'd have been
thinking i need water i was i mean i was
still
i was 200 yards from my car at that
point like it was i just gone up the
rocks
uh so i didn't have anything i had my
camera are you talking to yourself yet
a little bit whispering maybe oh because
i thought people might be able to hear
me
okay uh but i go back down i uh
cook myself some dinner i did my food
situation was
um a lot of those pre-packaged
i just add water okay because i was like
this the cleanup is minimal
and you're really hungry and everything
tastes good when you're camping so maybe
i'll be able to get away with this
and survival packs and i and what i did
is i
before the trip i was like i'm going to
try a bunch of different brands so i got
you know mountain house that's the one
everybody knows about right that's
that's the super popular one and then
there's another one
that i ended up liking the most just if
you're interested uh
i think it's called packet gourmet or
something it's like it's got the story
of like the
the couple that started it in the 70s
and now they've got kids and they all
work there
they make some really good grits grits
like the gr
you know when you put water in something
that's got meat in it sometimes it's
like man this is like meat that could
have been around until 2050
yeah that can't be great for you and it
definitely isn't great tasting
but the grits man they got a grit they
got multiple grits
packet people pack it yeah yeah yeah
pack it gourmet i don't know
anyway i had one of those i was like
pretty good and then the sun's about to
set at this point sun's going down
i uh i take out my journal and i decided
i'm going to do
the handwritten thing even though i'm
probably going to get hand cramps
because that happens to me
i was like i don't want to be using
rattlesnakes and hammer i don't don't
want to be used how's he going to
survive
the ipad or the computer because it just
it doesn't feel natural enough right so
i got my journal and i'm
starting to write and just kind of
making some observations dear journal
go to sleep day one quick review i'll
give a quick review of the rooftop tent
and then
we'll take a little break and and we'll
come back and i'll tell you about the
first morning and how that kind of
set the stage but um
rooftop tent definitely
an improvement over a regular tent
in terms of like sleep quality uh and
also just like
feeling of safety like you're on top of
this car and there's a ladder i mean i
guess like a bear could climb a ladder
but
um you just feel like you feel a little
bit
safer and you're you're literally
elevated circus they do a lot of things
i think they got to be trained to do a
ladder i think they do a tree naturally
but you got to train them for a ladder
um it's quick you open that thing up
it's
it's not as quick as as i wanted it to
be
so it's actually pretty quick to set up
your own because you got this big
leather cover basically rubber slash
leather whatever it is and you un it's
completely
zipped around three edges and you have
to unzip it fold it down
then you got to open it up put stick the
ladder in there
and then you gotta if you want like
airflow which the first night was kind
of hot you gotta like
put these supports like these
metal supports like they go into the
side of the thing and then they kind of
like
make the awnings taut and
i was like i think this took as long as
a regular tent like i think that the way
they make tents now which are like
and they're basically up i think this
didn't
take any less time but there's a
mattress on the whole bottom of it
there's a mattress on the bottom of it
plus i added an air mattress on top of
that mattress that's stored in there or
you
yeah yeah i mean you leave it you leave
it in there and it's a self-inflating
um self self-inflating mattress and then
i just kind of deflate it every morning
and then just fold it back up in the
tent no problem
um but definitely i i mean i definitely
recommend that
and and but you got to get it level and
like i was saying you
um i took those um rv blocks and made
sure it got level every single night did
you have a level
like a i thought about it i just used my
my intuition
yeah does this feel level does this look
level is this level
right and it ended up being a level uh
by that am i self-inflating
i will i over inflated the first night i
wanted i don't want to over i wanted it
to be hard because when you get an air
mattress that's soft and you wake up in
the middle of night and like it's down
your booty or your hip bone is like
touching the bottom
yeah what an uh what you know you went
too hard yeah
i went too hard i was like man i didn't
think i could go this hard
but i went way too hard and over
inflated but i pretty much got it right
the second day
um okay i'm gonna i'll get into talking
about get scared
didn't get scared that first night again
because i kind of
knew that there was somebody close by
there was a person close by and i want
to talk about that
okay in a little bit about why is it
that that brings so much comfort
but first um let's talk about these mugs
here mythical.com has everything
you could want that has anything to do
with us
and you because that's what this is
about it's about you
and me and him
having the same stuff you want to drink
like us having the same stuff
then that's what it drink out of this
it's a good mythical morning mug there's
different colors there's a third color
yeah there's a third color that's blue i
believe
uh that we don't even have right now but
you could have it you could be drinking
out of your blue mug
while we drank out of our green and
orange mug connect with us we'd be
a trilogy it makes you feel like you're
we're just over
the ridge you can't see us but if we
cranked up our car you could
right you could hear us if we slurped on
our mugs
that wasn't that close slurping would
have not come through you would have
felt it you would have to be in like a
slurp and a chicken
you also own one you have to slurp choke
and cough and then i would be able to
hear you
mythical.com almost dropped it okay so
first morning again i i wake up and i'm
like i don't know exactly where i'm
gonna go tonight
because the spring that i had designated
as my potential first stop
for a hot spring is in the national
forest is it
is deep in the inyo national forest
which is closed
so like i mean they're really enforcing
this like where am i going to get fined
am i getting arrested what
what what is it stake here
um but i was like you know what i just
said that right it's not the right thing
to do let's set that aside right now
and i'm just going to sit here and i'll
tell you the
most wonderful moments for me on this
trip
was waking up and first of all waking up
pretty early because i went to bed early
like you get out there especially when
you're by yourself
i mean it gets dark and you're kind of
like well yeah i guess i'll go to sleep
you know it's like it's like a farmer in
the old days it's like every human
before electricity
you get dark and you're like well what
do you do now george you go to sleep
did you have the stars like i was
talking about oh yeah
and you had the you told me you got a
special star gazing
tent i mean seat i did i got that that
was the main thing that i said
i told christie i was like we've got to
invest in some
camp chairs that are actually good
because those like
those cheap ones that you get from
dick's sporting goods they just wrap up
they're the worst for your for your
posture
well let me tell you definitely can't
see this let me tell you about these
anti-gravity chairs as they call it it's
freaking huge and i was like i could
take this by myself but i couldn't take
another person
i could take two of these you can take
oh gosh yeah
it was by far it was the biggest thing
in my truck was that damn chair
i i had convinced myself it was worth it
i think it might be and i'll talk about
that because i think night four is when
i really used it
okay full effect but go ahead and try to
connect with aliens well here um
but that first morning had my breakfast
got my coffee
that starbucks instant coffee the via i
i mean i tell you it's good man we got
some of that you don't i mean you don't
even really know that you're drinking
instant coffee yeah it's good so i'm
having a little coffee
and then i i'm full you know i'm full in
my belly
and i again go back to the journal
and i just start again i'm not going to
talk about what i was thinking about but
again my theme my my goal on the trip
was to
um be like water right to go with the
flow
to let go to not be this guy that has to
like analyze and
differentiate and categorize and analyze
every single thing that i'm encountering
and know exactly where i'm going to go
it would be like be like water
you know you face an obstacle and you
just go around it
that's the sound of water yeah um and so
i feel that i had this really
intense um
sort of sense that that was happening
even that first morning like it was
it's pretty powerful and uh you gave
yourself permission to not
just get on with anything it wasn't
about you
back to getting to the next thing yeah
you sat there and like i have space
right here right now
but the whole time this was a challenge
throughout the whole trip
when you when you're somebody who's not
like water but you're trying to be like
water
the consistent challenge when every
single
every single aspect of your trip is tbd
every single day
yeah am i going to run out of gas i'm
going to get a flat tire am i going to
really be able to change the tire
you know like am i going to be out of
service am i going to
um right when i get to this hot spring
are there going to be people there are
they going to have coveted
you know and this is how my brain works
i i i'm actually
considerably more anxious than i ever
realize or or even sort of put off the
people you know what i mean
i'm constantly think in the future i'm
constantly
thinking about all possible
options decisions that can be made
and the whole point of the trip was to
just be present
the first thing that i wrote in my
journal which
i just did digitally you know something
whatever on the first night before i
didn't get hand cramps first night the
thing that i the thing that i wrote down
i might have been the only thing i wrote
down was it is
hard not to think about the future
because even five minutes from now is
the future
so including that i i just that that was
the first
thing i was over overwhelmed with the
first thought was
it's really hard to not think about the
future i was
in exactly for that reason because
we were in control of our trips and
there's always a decision to be made
and you can make a better decision if
you anticipate or if you have a plan or
even if you're letting go of of
checking certain boxes or
achieving something or realizing
the perfect trip that you've visualized
in your mind you know
if even if you let go of all that your
mind still
goes to something else and it's
for me too it was in the future maybe
for some people it's in the past
oh yeah dealing with something but for
we're very alike in that way
um yeah so that i mean that was a
constant challenge but it also was very
evident to me
because i started thinking things like
maybe next time i'll just go to a cabin
i'll just drive to a cabin and i'll be
in the same place the whole time but
then it was like no
no no no no don't lose the opportunity
here right
the opportunity is to embrace the fact
that you don't know where you're going
to sleep
like that's part of what that's why
you're here man
yeah that's how you get out of the
future and get into the present is by
actually being
faced with the feeling of not knowing
right
and not going to know so first
one of the first unknowns was okay if i
can't go to this
hot spring that i wanted to go to where
can i go because there's another one
that i could go to but i've already been
told basically by the internet that it's
to be busy there's going to be people
there but i was like
screw it i mean it's a hot spring let's
just go check it out
so um i went to this hot spring i'm not
going to name the names because i can't
remember all the names and also
i the whole problem is that too many
people know about them
so i'm not going to talk about where
where i was fine tell me later but so
i go to this hot spring that is you know
uh north of the alabama hills in
california i know it's confusing but you
can you can hang on
and uh it's in the middle of a giant
like there's just so many just open
valleys that are just filled with
grazing cattle like it's just
throughout all of california and all of
nevada it's just a bunch of cattle
grazing in the middle of nowhere
is what it seems like way more cattle
than people as far as i can tell
and there's a hot spring out in the
middle of this cow field like
there's like a a walkway that they've
built over the cow pasture to kind of
keep you from like walking through cow
crap and mud and then it just
comes to this spring in the middle of
the field and there's literally like cow
[ __ ] around the spring and also cows
like looking at you as you're bathing
but what did they get in it and the
cow's doing it's too hot for the cows
so there's two springs one is the one
that obviously is preferred because
there's like
nine people in it and there's no room
for another person i mean maybe i could
get awkward and get in there but again
i'm thinking about covid and nobody's
got a message
dirt this is a natural this is natural
because all
most of the ones that we've both
experienced before now have been
uh like a tough cement line like well
they'll
they'll
redirect the water into something into a
tub or a pool
yeah but this was this was natural but i
see that there's like another thing down
there that's even
more i think actually the one that
everybody was in they may have
reinforced it with rocks
but the other one is just like the cow
pasture just kind of opens up and it's
uh like a foot and a half of water but
it's like 20 feet across
and there was just one woman laying in
there and
it was so shallow that like she's kind
of laying against the side
and like most of her body is out of the
water but she's still in the water i'm
like well i'm going to do what she does
and i was like
hey and i was you know
no nobody's naked she was fully bathing
suited okay
and uh i i sit down
and i'm like this is pretty nice
like i'm sitting in this 18 inches of
water you know my legs are under the
water and maybe
up to my belly button and then the rest
of me is out and then i'm kind of like
laying up against the side of the
the thing and on the grass and it's
pretty hot
and it's also pretty hot inside the
spring it's hot outside and inside
but i'm like this is cool this is not me
connecting with anything this is me
thinking about
this woman that's a cross you know i'm
saying like
not being able to disconnect from the
reality that there's another person here
and like am i sitting in a weird way you
know like just
being self-conscious in general right
yeah but also thinking about how
these people over in this other hot tub
are really loud and like laughing and
it's kind of boisterous
and then i was like oh crap here they
come three or four families come over
the horizon
and they descend on
this spring that i'm in and like there's
kids saying like
mom it stinks yeah like one kid's like
going
like gagging because of the sulfur yeah
and then everybody's like it's pretty
hot is it hot it's how hot is it is it
clean it's pretty clean like
this is not enjoyable and they all kind
of just sort of descend on this area and
then i just kind of get up i'm like i
don't want this
yeah i get up and i begin to walk over
to funny thing is
they didn't want it either yeah but just
like water you present me with an
obstacle
and instead of trying to go through it i
just go around it
and i go over to the other i start
walking towards the hot spring and all
those other people are turns out leaving
and there's just one dude in there and i
just
go and get into the spring first of all
it's like three feet deep it's deep
enough to sit down
but he's the guy says what's up duder
oh what's up duder
yeah you add the r on the end of dude
and you're not
conversation material and then the woman
who was on the other side walks over
and he's like hey babe and then i'm like
oh
they're a couple there i go they're a
married couple and boy let me tell you
i know everything there is to know about
them because he would not stop
talking he was one of those guys who is
just constantly
saying things but not necessarily add
anybody
anything that you need to hear no
talking a lot and saying nothing you
know what i'm saying which is why she
was all alone
over there just made two inches of water
just nice guy
making conversation but not the vibe
that i'm after
yeah you know and i'm not talkative in
those situations i'm more like right
yeah
uh-huh yeah you were given all the
signals to shut up
but i knew it was pointless so i was
like i'm gonna
oh and then eventually they were like
duder we gotta leave
they had to go on and i did get some
time
to myself in this but again you know
there's like a family over there
and and i was just like i just this
isn't what i wanted it to be
but that's i need to just embrace what i
need to embrace what it is but then i
was like okay
all right let's leave let's go let's go
to the next place
um and i was like i'm just going to kind
of just go
and just see where i feel led to stop
and camp because with this rig i can
basically just go off and go
there's all these dirt roads off the
side of the road the whole way
yeah and it's all public land you can
just go find a spot
so i drive off i drive up into
i get to a place i'm like this is a cool
like forest this isn't a desert this is
more like
forest i like forest i'll drive into
forest
would you so i drove into the forest
and started seeing like campsites the
roads started getting rougher and i was
like i would not be able to do this
without a four-wheel drive vehicle drove
around found a couple of spots
and then eventually kind of settle in a
place and first of all i was like i
haven't really seen
any fires yet like i'm not really close
to the fires but i haven't really
experienced a lot of smoke
but at that moment a wall of smoke
began to like roll through the forest
really
and i was like oh i'm at the perimeter
of the smoke cloud
either that or you're out of fire no but
i was looking on the map and i knew that
i wasn't near an actual fire
okay uh this was smoke coming from
the fire that's in the inyo national
forest but not where i was
okay and it was it wasn't one of these
situations where like it smells like a
campfire it was like no i am in a
campfire
like i cannot breathe normally this
everything began to smell like smoke i'm
breathing in smoke and i know that's not
healthy
so i'm like okay the universe is telling
me to move
flow right to the next place you're
doing it different than me
i'm gonna start doing here it's not in
the lips it's in the
mouth yeah and so i prefer the next
thing and i actually ended up
crossing over into nevada not like he
thought i was gonna cross over into the
supernatural
realm but no just into nevada to the
smoke monster and um
started working my way towards another
hot spring and this is again this is one
that
relatively popular on the internet
so i was like well we'll see and but
it's starting to get dark so i had to
find a spot and i get to
this spring and um
you can't camp next to the spring but
there's a i mean this is when it has a
parking lot
it's popular and then outside of the
parking lot like
half a mile from the entrance there's a
bunch of places to camp
and i kind of drove over a hill and
found a place that i couldn't see
anybody else and i was like all right
i'm going to
set up shop here but i'm like a mile
walk at this point from the spring
but i'm like you know what i'm going to
wait till it gets dark oh and you're
gonna and i'm gonna walk
to the spring and enjoy it of course
this is not an original idea everyone's
thinking the same thing apparently
so i walk to the spring and yes it is it
is
filled with people jumping
and but this spring most of the springs
have like the hot water source coming
into them and then there's a pool
and then like an overflow to a second
pool and overflow to a third pool each
pool getting
uh cooler cooler the first pool which is
the one you want to be in is clean
and it's not run off and it's hot
everyone's in that i didn't want to get
right next to everybody but also there
was no room
so i go to the second pool so the first
pool has like five dudes
middle-aged dudes no women
uh and then the second pool has an old
man in it
i was like is this old man with the
dudes i don't think so because he seems
his energy is very different was
nakedness happening at this no nakedness
it was also very dark but everybody had
on trunks as far as i could tell
so i'm like i'm gonna get into this hot
tub with this old man and i walk up
there first of all they're like how you
doing come on in the water's fine
like no duder this time no duder but
very much like a lot of dad
joke energy okay and this is coming from
a dad who makes jokes
but like not like this guy that i'll
talk about in a second but the second
hot tub with the old man in it
the old man says this one's taken
what and he's like just kidding
because you're you're susceptible right
anyone says this one's taken you're like
oh sorry i'll go to the third one oh
yeah yeah i'll talk about that in a
second
hot spring etiquette well i get in with
the old man now
it's not a big hot tub i mean there's
enough room for me and this old man
and the old man is on his
all fours and like putting one leg up in
the air really high and then bring it
down and putting the other leg he's
doing
what he calls calisthenics calisthenics
and then he gets on his back and he's
doing
all this other stuff and i'm like this
guy is alone he's not with the other
guys clearly
yeah this dude was a character he
started talking about
um he like traveled around with that
rainbow society thing you know what i'm
talking about like
um there's a group called uh i don't
it's like a vacuum cleaner
so it's like a i think it's some kind of
cult they like travel around in buses
oh like a rainbow society or something i
don't know what it is but
i mean it's like a hit bunch of hippies
yeah and he had been he had spent some
time with them
he he matches the profile and uh
but then dad number one i'll call him
that's what he would be in the script
yeah uh is sitting and he's the he's the
guy who's very loud
they're drinking coors light they're
very drunk oh gosh
and um the guy says
you guys know anybody who's got covered
what you guys know like anybody in your
inner circle got coveted
and of course i'm i'm not like i'm not
i'm not going to engage with this guy
so i don't say anything nobody else says
anything he's like yeah
that's what i thought i mean
i think it's a conspiracy
it's better than him saying well i do
you're looking at one
i'm in your circle and so i'm like is
this what hot tubs are
like hot tubs are coming down and
sharing your space with a very flexible
old man by the way very flexible yeah
yeah very flexible hips really it makes
your ligaments just
apply um and then a covet denier
he's like yeah you know hospitals get 37
000 for every cobit patient i mean
they're just doing it for the money
they're doing it for the money yeah i'm
just like am i do i
have to put do i have to listen to this
[ __ ] do i have to listen to it
i guess i do i guess i do because the
water feels good
it did feel good and i was not in a how
hot
um i could tell that the main based on
the temperature of the second tub the
main tub would have been hotter than a
hot tub
like like 110 no probably 120. oh like
could you scald yourself if you're not
careful
like you can't go in up to your neck and
like just stay there unless you just
really are
oh go out for it because it's like but
they can take it and they can reroute it
so it cools down a little bit
anyway i was like i'm not in a because
you know me i've got the tendency to be
like
well let me tell you why it's not a
conspiracy and you're full of crap
listen you know yeah but i don't
typically do that with with strange
strangers
so but i was like i'm definitely not
going to say anything to this guy
he's not interested in he's not
interested in the truth anyway
but so i kind of stuck around for a
little bit and then
i kind of walked the mile back to my
campsite
and as i was walking back i was i was
just like i don't know i don't know
about hot springs it's like
am i gonna find one that i can have to
myself
now bear in mind that the next morning i
had my time my coffee
i'm i'm listening to multiple books as i
travel these distances and
some of those books are really uh i'll
talk about one of them
one of the ones that was more of the fun
lessons i listened to like three books
throughout the trip but i'm listening to
ones that are a little bit more serious
a little bit more about spiritual things
contemplative things and uh again i'm
still having a really good time in my
soul but the expectation of what hot
springs
i mean i'm beginning to think that this
is a lesson that i'm being taught a
lesson that like
you're going around looking for these
hot springs that ain't where it's at
you're not going to find what you want
you cannot place this expectation on
these hot springs because it's going to
be
old flexible old men and cova deniers
and etc
you know but i head on to the next one
again my
destination is determined by where the
next hot spring is so
i get to one that is supposed to be one
of the best ones
and i get to it and i'm like is that it
it's a cow tub it's like something you
would like put feed or water in for a k
for cows like a circle metal tub
something we would get the like bathing
on the show but much bigger
okay and dirty and of course the water
kind of stinks because it's like sulfur
and i kind of parked next to it and i
realized there's
all these people at all these campsites
that we all have a line of sight
to the spring i'm like maybe it's just
bad etiquette to like park right next to
the spring because they're all saying we
all use the spring you can't just like
set your campsite up right next to the
spring even though there's a fire ring i
didn't really know the etiquette
but i did as i looked around saw my
first had my first encounter with
full nakedness there we go but i'm also
thinking like
i what they're gonna
they're gonna come to this cow tub i'm
gonna be here
question mark and then and then i'm like
listen not to
not to
[Music]
i have a hot tub at home okay you know
can i just say that it took you three
days to
come to that realization you went all
the way across the country
looking for something that you had at
home oh that well that's an analogy that
i'll talk about in a little bit but
i have a hot tub at home that is a
clean b
i can dial in the temperature on my
phone
yeah yeah c right
i determine who goes in it right and how
much clothes they have on
right these people that i choose it's my
property
yeah you're the king of the castle no
cows
no algae it doesn't smell like sulfur
it's filtered
it's right out in my backyard now i know
that's a privilege thing to have to be
able to have a hot tub at your house
i'm blessed i'm privileged um
but i also am looking for hot tubs
throughout the
nation yeah hot springs yeah and i got a
hot tub at home this is interesting yes
um that's better and it hit me at that
point so i was like i'm not
i was like you know what i'm sounds like
an opportunity to journal
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
bypass this i'm gonna get back in my
truck and i'm just gonna go up into the
woods and find a parking space
a camping space because the thing that
i'm after is solitude and reflection yes
contemplation there you go
i go up the uh way into the woods
to the point where i'm like there's only
one way out of here and there
you go now i'm what if there's a forest
fire here right but i'm like
screw it or a dude with photos i don't
know yeah right i'm setting up here
who knew what you had to fear and this
was the first night
that i set up in a place where
i was i had my map and i've gotten i had
no service but i've got my
uh satellite phone deal so i just feel
safe and connected in some way and i
know where i'm at i can get out of here
but this is when as it's starting to get
dark i start to think about
bears mountain lions
killers you know yeah um
funny thing is i didn't think about any
of that until i met one
well okay so but i was i wasn't alone
you know i think that makes a big
difference
and it gets to the point where it gets
dark and
your eyes adjust to the light in your
immediate vicinity
and it was it was a new moon so the
moonlight on our trip and you probably
noticed this the starlight was
incredible there was no moon no
very very little moon i think the the
beginning of the trip was the new moon
it was
up during the day but then it went it's
set before night or something
but so no moonlight so when it gets dark
you've got your little lantern there
and that's in your headlamp you can't
see anything and it's just every
direction is just
pitch black and what could be in that
dark
really started to kind of freak me out
and you know i told the story a long
time ago about the time i went down to
like burn
some stuff um when i was working for my
father-in-law
and in the woods yeah and uh we're like
burning
it was back when they had to keep
everybody's uh you know
medical records you had to keep
everybody's records as as a
as paper paper and then i think it was
just like old patients who had left or a
diet or whatever and so
you could shred them or you could just
burn them whatever i don't know exactly
how it works 20 years ago
but i would be out there burning and
then
uh and i had recently watched the ring
and so i think that the little girl from
the ring is gonna like come up out of
nowhere and i start getting this image
in my mind
well one of the reasons that in the lost
causes of bleak creek that the
uh not villain if you will but like
one of the scary things in there is the
is
spoiler alert the little girl
ruby yeah because the idea of a little
girl that sort of got something
demonic inside her is the thing that is
one is the most scary thing for me
and um i when i get out there alone
i think about her i know i i begin to
like think that like i'm gonna turn
around and there's gonna be like a
little
possessed girl like on all fours turned
over backwards like
crab crawling i mean like like and then
the moment i think about it i'm like
you're an idiot you're a 42 year old man
out here
scared of the dark and you think you're
thinking about things you've seen in
horror movies yeah yeah and then i like
laugh it off and then i like
you know start like making my dinner and
then i'm like
looking over your shirt turn around yeah
here's something i'm like yeah she here
now
wow and uh and then i'm like man this is
this
if i if i knew that there was somebody
100 yards away i wouldn't be thinking
about this
like just the proximity to another
person and i was like
isn't that i was like what does that say
about me that i want to be isolated
but i want to know where other people
are and when i don't know how far i am
from other people i begin to imagine
that there's possessed people who are
close
it's like what's going on with me so i
gotta i so eventually
after it gets too dark i get up in my
tent and
i go to sleep but then that morning i
woke up
and again same thing good mo
like once the morning comes the little
girl can't come yeah it's how physics
works
she hates it she died i cannot come out
into the light
so i drove so i had the nice morning i
drove down i drove to a cave
that had pictographs from thousands of
years ago wow
and it also had metal bars that they put
on the full
face of the cave so you can't get in
there and screw them up because people's
like why people gotta be like that
why can't you just not screw with the
pictographs why you gotta put
metal gates on the front of it because
even the most well-meaning people
they're gonna touch it they're gonna
touch stupid they're gonna just reach
out and touch it and rub it
before they've thought about if they
should do that or not
um you rub a pictograph for thousands of
years
it's just a rock yeah but it was pretty
cool took some pictures of that
that was the write down your journal
tokuma cave i think it's called
and uh that sounds right i mean i took
pictures and i was like man what were
they trying to say
it looks like just circles and lines
maybe they were just like let's draw
circles and lines yeah
probably uh or maybe this is like
representative of some sort of contact
they made with aliens which i'm going to
try to do tonight i mean it could have
been a football coach like doing the
offensive play
yeah ancient football so
then again i i've got the cool thing is
i've got this uh
i've got my app the gaia
app and i've pre-downloaded all the maps
for this area
for all the places i'm gonna go and it's
got layers that you could turn on like
this is the u.s forest service this is
the
topography what is this girl there this
is
uh your cell phone service coverage like
you can see where you're going to get
into cell phone service
buy carrier i needed that um
so super easy to turn and then you can
download all the maps out of that anyway
so i saw that there was a ghost town
down like an hour down i mean he's only
like 15 miles away but because of the
crazy roads and stuff it just
take me an hour to get there but a ghost
town that had a hot spring oh
and i'm like okay all right this house
fine double so
there's this part of nevada near that to
now there's these uh sort of the hills
that have all the trees on them that are
like conifer trees of some kind like you
know
some kind of pine tree and it's really
awesome because they're like not super
thick and they just have this sort of
like fairy tale quality to them yeah but
then when you get to the base of them it
just turns into just
field with and there's usually cattle
and people have made ranches out of all
this stuff
but dirt roads would just go forever
yeah and so i go down this dirt road and
i get to
a place called potts ranch i think it
was
and uh it's just an old house an old
farmhouse and like a barn
that looked like they've been abandoned
for many many generations
that's cool for many many decades uh but
probably been around since like
you know 1800s or whatever did you walk
through it yeah i took some pictures and
uh walked in a little bit but it was
like the floor was falling apart
i'll share some of that those pictures
and um i bet you weren't thinking i'm
going to camp here tonight no because i
wasn't far enough i hadn't moved far
enough i needed to keep moving in order
to kind of get back to a place where i
could be close to home by the end of the
trip
and this is i'm almost at my furthest
point away from home i'm kind of in the
middle of nevada at this point
um but i i'm like okay but there's a hot
spring here
here's where it's out on the map and i
kind of went past the house and went
down this dirt road
and i get down i'm like oh yes this is
going to be awesome there's nobody
around for miles
and i get down there and i'd seen a
picture of the of the hot spring on the
internet because i had service for a
second
and it was the same deal it was like
there's a creek and they
they've run the creek through a pipe
into a tub
i get down there the tub's gone the pipe
literally
just is there into and just goes onto
the ground huh
they've removed the tub the tub a ghost
there's just a little pool there
that they've kind of dammed up that's
about six inches deep
so i just like sat there and stuck my my
feet in there
like a poor little boy
it felt great but i was like how awesome
would this be if the tub was here why
are you gonna take the time away
you should have brought your own tub
next time man i thought about it i was
like could you have a
cloth a baby pool that you inflate and
then
like a mobile hot tub it's got to be
like made of kevlar
yeah but uh i make those for like really
rambunctious i did have my first shower
there
i know i had been in a couple of hot
tubs but i had my solar shower
like heated the water up with the sun
you talk about a sack
it's a sack with a tube yeah yeah
basically
solar shower sounds more sophisticated i
shower myself i use soap
i wash my parts um it feels good it
feels great
you haven't washed your parts in a few
days you gotta wash your parts
and uh and i had it was naked in the
middle of a field
yeah were mountains on both sides and
just
valley as far as i could see both ways
and i was like this is
this is pretty awesome i mean i wish
that the tub was here but this is pretty
awesome
and i began it's funny the moment that
my whole perspective began to shift from
like
are you learning your lesson yet you
come with these expectations
drop your expectations man that's the
whole point of this you got to drop the
expectations
the tub may not be there it doesn't
matter yeah take a shower wash your
parts
it's not something you can just reflect
on it i i think it's
it the way you say it it does seem like
it's like
i should have known this i should have
just realized this you have to
experience but i actually
i think that that's the thing that i'm
learning what i was saying in the last
one too was like
it made sense when people talked about
connecting with nature or connecting
with themselves in nature connecting
with god and nature
you know whatever your intention is um
it makes sense and but it's different to
actually experience it
and i think i guess that's true for just
lessons in life is that like
the strongest lessons you learn are the
ones that you experience
and which is comforting as a parent you
know think about that in terms of
in terms of your kids too that like you
can't protect them from everything and
it's like that's the most powerful way
to
to to change who you are as a person is
to go through
things and so but i
maybe i'm hearing too much and what
you're saying that it almost feels like
i had to go through this in order to
learn it but it's like well no there was
i went through this and i was
able to learn it that's it it's very
much what happened listen i had my
therapy
appointment last night to kind of follow
up for my trip um
and of course i ended up sharing
everything that happened to me
internally
which even that morning when i'm taking
my shower and sitting next to this hot
creek and stuff there's
there was a lot of things i was just
sort of realizing and
more than just the surface level yeah
this trip represents
my life in a lot of ways and the way
that i live and the things that i seek
it's not just something you can write
down it's not something that just
happens in your brain
it's what i think we're saying yeah
and and that was a big i'll share a
little bit of that because i think that
was one of the biggest realizations on
the trip is that
uh i you know i've talked about how i
live in in my mind and i'm
yeah i'm a victim of my thoughts which
is a very normal thing but
um that you know heart knowledge
experiencing things
something just being true because it
is not because you can rationalize it
explain it analyze it break it down and
present it to someone else
but something that you can just
experience and sort of know
intrinsically
like access inside yourself um
was something that was just very
visceral and very powerful that was
continuing to happen throughout the trip
yeah but that day now you know i brought
the special chair
i had intentions to try to connect with
aliens now the thing i didn't talk about
is i
listened to the 30 minute guided
meditation from dr stephen grier
in the in the in the ce5 i think is what
app
um again this is from that netflix
documentary which i was fascinated by
again i don't believe it i don't close
encounters of the fifth or the fifth
kind what it's called and basically the
fifth kind representing
essentially uh a cosmic connection to
aliens not like just seeing them
physically but
it's it was interesting receiving a
signal it's based on the fact that
if there is something to the idea of a
collective consciousness of the universe
then other intelligent life out there is
a part of that and we can
if we get into that sort of what you
want to call it metaphysical
spiritual plane there is some way to
have a connection now
again the rational part of my brain
which is
very dominant in my mind uh in
my personality is like this is almost
assuredly [ __ ] right
like i would be uh flummoxed if this
were to be
if this were to be true right if you're
really if you really could connect with
aliens in this way
but also why the hell not try
who am i going to hurt if i try and
wouldn't it be cool if it could happen
so tonight i'm going to try
because i finally listened to like the
way he kind of talks about
the meditation process and how you're
supposed to like basically
broadcast where you're at so they'll
find you
right so but i see this hot spring on
the map that i'm not too far from and
i'm like well
let's go let's go there maybe there'll
be a tub
and it was funny the moment that my
expectations
completely evaporated is the moment that
i found the best hot spring experience
this is the next to last night
a stop at a place that i'm not going to
tell you where it's at because i hope to
return to it
but i go there
and there is two large
families with two large trailers who are
camped right next to the spring i'm like
ah crap
and they're getting out of the spring
like they've been bathing like they've
taken a little break or whatever
and i kind of just drive up to the
spring because i'm like i'll just you
know i wasn't planning on camping there
i was like i'm just going to take a dip
take a soak and uh
i'm like oh you guys got a good spot and
he's like well we're leaving
oh and he's like you do that and he was
like and i just cleaned
the hot tub so basically it was a
heart-shaped stone tub
that the way it works is again they all
work the same way you've got the hot
water source from the spring that
somebody has piped into this thing
it fills up and then it kind of goes out
over a spillway but there's a plug in
the bottom of a lot of these that you
can pull
so it'll drain and then you can scrub it
and the dude because they had been there
for a few days
antelope hunting didn't know that was
something that happened they had two
antelopes already
like draped over their trailer or
something uh butchered or something
they i didn't see him he just said we've
killed two huh
he drained and scrubbed the thing he had
drained and scrubbed it and he had just
filled it up and he like showed me how
it worked
that's cool and then they left and i was
like
oh yes am i about to have a heart-shaped
tub all to myself
no i'm not oh because and now this is
like two o'clock i was like there's no
way no one's gonna show up
but i was like you know what i'm gonna
stay here
i'm gonna camp here so i go ahead and i
take my rooftop tent out
set it up i'm probably i don't know what
the etiquette is but i'm probably
closer to the hot spring than i should
be but i was like i want to get in it
you know not that nobody else is going
to get in it but i'm probably 100 feet
from it
so it's pretty close okay and then up
rolls
two cars two older couples get out
and they walk up to me and they're like
so uh is that the spring
and then it hits me i'm like they think
i'm an authority
yes because i'm here and because i'm
close to the spring
they assume that i have some sort of
intrinsic authority here
yeah this is how people's brains work
you can use it against them
and i was like you could say no yeah
it's just been cleaned
oh no i was no it's dirty no no no
i played it like this i'm going to be
generous with the spring
okay i'm the keeper of the spring that's
what these people believe
i'm going to be generous i said it's
just been clean it should be
it should be warmed up for you and
they're like well we're just going to
stay for a little bit i mean don't want
to if you don't mind
it's like this is working and i'm like
take all the time you want
as if i have any authority at all but
i'm just going with it because they seem
to be going with it okay
but you could you could also told them
take 10 minutes
because if you give somebody a limit
they naturally want to exceed it ah
don't give them a lemon just be generous
be nice and then they're like i'ma give
him his space
then they said he lives here they were
from look at his beard they were from
ohio
ah i said you know chuck testa and they
were like oh yeah the commercial
i was like i made that commercial
and boy that got me some brownie points
seriously yeah yeah yeah they're like he
keeps the spring and he makes
commercials
how does he do it all because that is
all
and so i talked to them for a while
and uh you were in the spring no no no i
was
i i was standing over it keeping it i
was sitting
in my alien chair oh yeah next to my
truck
on this side where you had to walk past
me to get to the spring
uh that couple ended up leaving another
couple showed up a younger couple
yeah that was the hashtag van life
couple when i was taking the pictures
that i told you about during your story
yeah priorities out of whack they ended
up being really cool they stayed
the night and an older man stayed the
night
now not really close to me
and the way it ends up working is you
end up spending
you could spend about 10 or 15 minutes
in a really hot hot tub this was
the temperature of the water was 130
degrees coming out of the pipe so you'd
have to like
fill it up and then divert it or
put a restrictor in the pipe there's a
very engineering behind these things is
pretty cool
put a restrictor in it so it's not quite
filling up fast enough and it's slowly
losing temperature so it probably gets
down to like 110
and so that night i just got into the
hot tub
by myself for 20 30 minutes
looked at the stars
everyone was completely quiet they were
they were both gone they were in their
in their in their
fan and in their camper asleep not
talking
and i'm just out there and i'm like man
this is awesome i get it
like i'm in this heart-shaped hot tub
and then it hit me like
oh i need to reach out to the aliens
yeah so i began the meditative process
i went through the steps which ended
with me i'm in the heart-shaped hot tub
you know the one
oh yeah because you start you start with
the galaxy with the galaxy
move to the solar system and funnel your
move to your signal down
you move to the north america you move
the
american
specific bearings yeah and let me tell
you
that was the moment right you're like
i'm right here i'm here i'm like you
can't miss me
heart-shaped hot tub
and the thing i can most closely relate
it to is the time i tried to speak in
tongues
uh in new york when i was trying to
share the gospel with the man on the
bench who couldn't speak english and i
was like
lord this is when this is when i this is
when i speak
in tongues this is it and i was like
almost we're going to open my mouth and
to see what happens you know
because i was under the understanding
that speaking in tongues was for
evangelistic purposes not for the
edification of the body
theological stuff that no one cares
about okay unless you're one of those
people who cares about it
anyway um
they didn't come they didn't show up i
did it twice
and i was so i was so committed i was
like i am willing to believe this
like if you just show up i am here i'm
ready
there's also other people here it didn't
happen it didn't happen
be quiet no i'm not saying i'll never
try again but i tried so hard that night
i can't imagine trying harder but dr
steven greer suggests doing it in a
group
they were there you were in the
leadership position
you have to have commitment from
everybody i think you're gonna have
buy-in that would have been a lot to ask
um well but i but it was an incredible i
was gonna say sorry but you know what
water yeah yeah i was fine i was like i
wasn't supposed to meet the aliens on
this on this trip
now i know i'm getting a little bit long
as i got there's something significant i
got to talk about sure
next next to the the before the last
night
i um i'm like okay i gotta find a i
gotta find a place to stop here
i was kind of doing the game that you
were doing which is i want to get kind
of close to vegas because
that's gonna be close to home that's
like four hours from home but it's hot
down there so where am i gonna go
so i stopped about an hour outside of
vegas north of vegas
in uh some sort of higher mountainy
areas it's still kind of deserty but
about 10 degrees cooler because of the
elevation
and as i was looking for my
campsite i passed by this sign it said
trilobite fossil area
oh and i was like oh well i've always
wanted to find a fossil it's one of my
dreams
i've never found one i've searched i've
searched the world over
well i've looked on the side of the road
a few times yeah so
i'm like well let me find my campsite
first then i'll come back to this area
because i want to kind of know where i'm
going to sleep
10 minutes down the road i find a spot
way down in this dirt road next to this
pile of rocks where i did enough camping
but i go back to the trilobite fossil
area
you park your car and you walk up this
path and i like hear a
kid's voice and i had not i hadn't seen
another car and it felt like i was in
the middle of nowhere so i was like oh
is that the aliens here in the form of a
child
now have kids too it was just a family a
human family oh
and they were uh getting the fossils
there's the shale deposit out there
where there's this millions
you know of trilobites mostly just heads
and some full bodies but really now i
didn't see any of them yet
um but like it's this shale it's these
very flat rocks that you pick up and i
was like what do you do just i start
talking to the family when you just turn
rocks over they're like
well actually we have a hammer and you
have to
hit the rocks and they'll split and then
you see if there's fossils in there i'm
like
ah i've got an axe in my truck i'll go
get it
it's like as i said i was like i'm going
to kill you is what they heard
yes that way you don't run when i come
at you with an i'm going to get my ax
family
so uh i turn around i go to get my
little axe and i'm coming back down the
path and they're running and no
i get back and a little boy is crying
i'm like i'm just gonna use it for the
fossils i'm not gonna kill you with it
uh the little boy is crying because he's
locked his keys
his parents keys in their car oh and
they're like can you help us
and i'm like oh i don't really wanna
help anyone right now
i'm about to get a fossil i mean i can
bust your window
it's getting dark you know i gotta i'm
here for my fast gosh
uh but i'm like sure what happened there
like he liked the keys in the car
our campsite where our campers at is
just a couple miles down the road could
you take
could you take us i was like well i got
room for one which sounds like something
a serial killer would say
i realize that now but i only had room
for one did you have pictures that you
wanted them to vote on
because you are becoming i showed them
all my pictures
and uh you want to sell them so i took
the dad
and he got the key and came back and
they were like super appreciative
whatever that was my biggest fear by the
way i only had one key to the sprinter
van and i was i think it's smart enough
not let you lock it when the keys are in
it but
i was very anxious about it i had an
extra for that reason
now uh you were but here's the thing it
was rescued him it was a give and take
i saved the day for them they would
probably be dead without me
sure um but the thing that they provided
well they would have killed the kid
they had a vanguard yeah the thing that
they provided is the method how to get
fossils
yes i would have been out there turning
rocks over and let me tell you i would
have never
found anything because you have to split
the rocks because everyone's turned the
rocks over
they had found three of these things so
i was confident that i was going to find
one and but i was like it's getting dark
but i'm going to find my first ever
fossil and then i began to attach
a lot of expectation to finding the
fossil and the sun was going down
and i'm frantically running around
hitting these rocks and i'm like i'm
never
gonna find a fossil i'm not a guy that
finds fossils
you're moving fast i'm having a little
bit of a pity party okay and then and
then i'm trying other things like
maybe if i close my eyes and walk
and just set my hands down i will be
directed to where the fossils are yeah
i'm trying
you were sincerely thinking that oh i
did that
if you had to watch me it would have
been like i just leaned back
and then i was like i sensed a fossil
and i would go down and touch it and try
nothing that's like i mean that's like
praying to win your recreation soccer
game yeah which i also used to do
yeah right so the other thing that i so
then i was like okay well it's getting
dark
i you know what three more rocks and
then i'd do three and not find them
okay two more rocks yeah i kept doing
that strategy until i
finally found one hi now i don't have it
with me because
the reason i didn't bring it is because
i'm afraid that if i showed it to you be
like that's a fossil
you know what i'm saying it's like it's
not impressive it's the head of a
trilobite it's really small
it's very clearly a fossil if you really
look at it but it's not like
this thing ain't going in the
smithsonian you know what i'm saying
like and all the ones out there
are like oh i can see the outline of
where this thing died but it's not this
even a discoloration as much as it's an
imprint of this
okay ancient crustacean or whatever they
are but it's special to you it's special
to me and it's sort of my
is it what is the word talisman talisman
amulet uh for my trip you know oh yeah
it's sort of a souvenir souvenir that
i kind of hold on to the significant
life
things that happened because i've got
this thing to kind of hold on to
whatever
pocket i found so i found that then the
last night of camping
camping next to a rock pile
a big rock pile
and in the middle of this giant valley
there's this giant rock pile
kind of like the joshua tree type rocks
but a little bit different
and i get there as it's getting dark
it's the sun has already gone down but i
got it really set up really quickly
and i like get out of the car and i'm
like what what was that
a bat you're afraid of bats i hate bats
and i have set up next to a bat cave oh
because there's multiple bats coming out
of the giant rock pile
i'm like i sat up next to a bat cave and
i'm not batman you know how they see
they see by yelling at you and they're
attracted to bugs
and i'm the only source of light in this
valley what do bugs like
lights so i'm like well
i'm gonna see if i can do everything in
the dark
seriously i'm so afraid of bats that i
was like i'm gonna cook my dinner in the
dark
i'm gonna do everything in the dark i
kept lights off and i was able to do
almost everything in the dark there's a
few things i had to turn the lights on
for
uh and at that point there were moths
coming up to me and the bats were coming
to the moths like
it was a little freaky they didn't they
didn't attack me
um but i got in my tent that night
and this is where this i'm now i'm
finally getting to these
these two realizations one related to uh
our conversation and another one sort of
a larger scale thing but
also kind of related so
2 30 in the morning i wake up
and i'm like this doesn't happen to me
like i
i wake up in the middle of night but
take a whiz go back to sleep whatever
you know
yeah but uh i'm like i can't sleep and
then i could not stop thinking
it was very weird because it was very
vivid
i could not stop thinking about how
polarized our country is like it was
very strange
and i think it had something to do with
the fact that
you know i had been thinking about these
wildfires the whole time that i'm on
this trip and i've been trying to avoid
the smoke and i knew i was about to go
back into the smoke
um and i've been on the internet a
little bit like if i had service i was
like checking in you know there was a
few things happening
um like a few emails or whatever that i
like looked at i wasn't completely
disconnected i tried not to like set
some unrealistic standard for myself but
i was like i'm not going to be on the
internet very much but if i have service
i might check something
yeah and i made the mistake of like
going on twitter a couple of times and
of course
when you think when you go to twitter
especially twitter i mean facebook
which i don't go to because it's even
worse but
everyone has an opinion about these
wildfires right
and so you and of course i had been
around the kova denier guy and i was
like
i'm just like i'm looking at what people
are saying about the wildfires on
on online and this you know what our
president is saying about the wildfires
and there's this you know there's this
narrative that oh this is a the problem
with
the west coast is forest mismanagement
right like that's what's causing these
wildfires it's not climate change
climate change is a hoax
and i'm just like this is so it's just
so disheartening right it's just so
disheartening that
um we're dealing with something so
tragic that we're just beginning to deal
with it it's going to be just
continued further tragedy
for the coming decades and
it is related to climate change but you
know what
there is also an element of forest
mismanagement that contributes to it
right
it's not one or the other
it actually both contribute to it
but we're so divided that you can't give
in
you have to be on one side or the other
and if you believe that it's forced
mismanagement you
have to believe that climate change is a
hoax even though
i'm not going to give all the arguments
for climate change but it's happening
and it is
almost assuredly caused by humans and if
you're on that side of it
then you won't listen to anybody who's
got anything to say that's other than is
this is just climate change no it has
nothing to do with forest
management that's you it's not
california those are national forests
and
but you know i'm not going to get into
the details of it but
there the thing that really just kind of
like i could not go back to sleep as i
was like
so and it was related to some of the
stuff that i was reading about
in the way that we dig in
so deeply and identify with our position
and we think of ourselves as democrats
and republicans
christians atheists whatever and we we
we get into our group and we just
we we uh
put these shields around us and those
shields are
cannot be penetrated by anybody else's
ideas yeah
and i mean i really think that it's
it will be our downfall the the problems
that we
that we face as a species are so
large uh and there's so many of us
that this our level of division is going
to it will be our downfall
and and that's the hopeful conclusion i
was waiting for yeah
well no and i was just like wow i can't
stop thinking about this
but related to that as i was driving
back
and again this is related to a book that
i was reading which i'm not going to
talk about what book i was reading
and that kind of made me think about
these things because maybe i'll talk
about it at a different time
but i thought about our conversation
the conversation that we had about me
believing that you were as competitive
as me
now i'll say i have looked at what
people have said about the
about you know a few people have talked
about what they thought about the
conversation and kind of
analyzed uh thank you for those of you
who have contributed to that
conversation
i mean i definitely got the impression
that a lot of people were like why did
you guys end up talking about that for
an
hour and uh and the reason we ended up
talking about that for an hour is
because of me because
i thought that it was going to be you
know i never intended
for us to talk about i thought i was
going to say i think you're just as
competitive as me and we'd have a 10
minute conversation about it and it
would be
light-hearted and it would end somewhere
where
yeah you'd be like yeah i am
but the moment that you were like i
don't think so
i i was like okay well
i do think so and it became this
hour-long
conversation about it and
basically what i realized is that and
this is
i mean this is my tendency my tendency
is to
um have a have an opinion have a
perspective
and then be very invested
in getting whoever i'm talking to to
agree with my
perspective right
and one of the things that kind of
clicked based on some stuff that i was
reading
is that all arguments all debate
all sort of obsession with wanting to be
right
is based in an over-identification with
our mental position in other words
i become invested in
this opinion that i have which by the
way is not even something that i
really care about whether or not you're
competitive or whether or not you see
how you are as competitive is not an
important thing this is not something
that impacts my life
your life this is just a conversation
almost a philosophical inconsequential
debate of kind right but i was invested
in um
you proving to you that you actually
think the same way i do
and that's based in ego
and it's based in me identifying myself
with my position
but also ultimately my fear of death
and let me explain that and this is this
is kind of mind-blowing
but basically you know humanity's
one of humanity's big problems is this
over identification with
something uh that is a thought that you
have
in a way that you identify yourself like
i talked about a second ago like this
division that's in our country
and by having once you identify yourself
with an opinion
you actually translate your own
existence
into that opinion being being
uh maintained and spread
and that's where it gets into this like
trying to protect your own existence
so what i'm saying is is that i identify
myself with this
this argument because i feel like if i
can get you to agree with me if i can
get you to think like i do on this
then that kind of validates me it
validates my own existence
and if i'm not able to do that then and
i've identified i placed some of my own
personal identity
in that position if that position isn't
true there's a little bit less of me
around uh it's a fascinating concept
you're saying you discovered this about
yourself more so than you're saying
i discovered how everybody operates i
discover
i think i had this realization that both
things were happening because
the first thing that happened is this
overwhelming like sense of burden
about how divided the country is yeah
and being really mad
about the country being divided and also
having a very interesting perspective
that i bring to that because
i'm somebody that's been on both sides
of the political spectrum in my adult
life
um so i feel like i have an appreciation
for both sides it's like i know
how conservatives think and i know how
liberals think because i've had
very similar thought patterns to both of
them
but then realizing that on a small scale
and maybe an inconsequential scale i had
demonstrated that i'm just as big a part
of the problem
just in that little conversation we had
now i appreciate what people had to say
when they were like oh i'm so glad you
guys had that conversation
and you're able to have like this
conflict without being mad at each
other and you kind of demonstrated how
to have healthy conflict and
if that's what came from it then great
i'm glad we had the conversation
but i realize that
not just that conversation but the way
that i think in general
even when i did my deconstruction story
as much as i was trying really hard
because i know my tendency
to be persuasive but just to be
expository and just tell my story
i know that i have a tendency i want to
justify
myself i want to validate my own
position
because i i've got a big ego
and i want to perpetuate my own ideas
because i have
over identified with ideas as
inconsequential
as thinking that you need to realize how
competitive you are
and the details of the argument are kind
of they don't even matter
it just becomes this um
i it i just kind of like i dug in and
said
let's have this conversation and
hopefully it will end with you agreeing
with me
and i and i think that that is
um it's a small picture of what's
happening
not just nationwide but worldwide it's
just a
preoccupation with being right
you know you know what i'm saying
identifying
with an idea and then being validated in
that idea
because that validates you as a person
or people as people
and the way that
ideology identification
with a particular political party
particular worldview
particular religion whatever
it isn't it comes with a whole set of
things
that you have to embrace right like how
did it ever get to the point where
identifying as a follower of jesus
went hand in hand with being
extremely capitalist right
how did how did we get to a place um
where you know identifying yourself as a
follower of jesus meant denying that
humans are causing climate change right
like i i think we got there because
it's a package you take the package
and and um and i'm not saying listen i'm
not
judging what i'm saying is that i'm
guilty of it as well
i'm beginning to try to explore okay
well where else has this manifested
itself
outside of just a dumb argument about
how competitive you are
but ultimately what i'm saying is that
we had that conversation and it became
this big thing
because not even because i thought that
it was important but because
i made the statement and then i felt
like i had to defend it
i felt like i had to defend it for an
hour worth of conversation
you know i think that uh
that's not the typical that's not how
things typically play out in our
friendship dynamic i think it it wasn't
what you expected to happen again it was
like
you thought there would be a little
playful conversation and then an
agreement
i think with a lot of things going
through life together
there has this there has been this
dynamic of
um you know if we're exploring an idea
or if
if if if you're more intent on exploring
an idea
then you can bounce it off me and most
more often than not i would
explore it with you and and validate
that position
and i i think that's uh i just i do
think that's an interesting dynamic that
you know i didn't realize was happening
and i
you know it was like from
if someone was looking at my life they
might say
well you just glom onto whatever rhett
believes or whatever or um
uh you believe whatever he tells you
will be like a severe
and non-charitable way to put it because
that's not actually true
or if they and but what i never thought
of
is with you like talking about how this
because i didn't
i didn't know how this worked in your
own mind but if
hearing that someone may say
link fulfills a role in your life to
validate
that part of yourself that's that's
associated with
ideas potentially potentially like i
again i don't know
but it does i i do see a i mean
there is that pattern because i think
again you're exploring how you interact
with ideas and
and identity and again it's like i don't
have to say
i have that exact same experience in
order
to validate your your realization or
your confession well even now and i
think for me to say
i don't relate to that it's like it's
not about this conversation it's not me
at all it's one thing
it's because i mean it's one thing to be
like
so are you saying you shouldn't have
opinions about things you shouldn't
argue for
things it's like well i mean i think
we're in we're in we're in a place in
our country where i think that there are
principles
and there are people that need to be
advocated for and there are things that
need to be stood for
so i think that being a person of
principle
of character and integrity and standing
for things i'm not saying you shouldn't
have opinions and convictions
but we but we've talked about how we
also value i mean with our
deconstruction stories
how much we value open-mindedness and
like
not not skipping from one entrenched
thing belief system
just to another one but and but it's
less about where we're entrenched that's
a different conversation
than just talking about our value of
open-mindedness and not ruling anything
out
in order to well and i think that the
challenge
is hap finding a way to have a
an opinion a belief a conviction to
fight for something
but not to overly identify with it to
the point that your self-worth and your
self-identity is
based in some position that you have
right um because at that moment
you become more committed to your
position than you do to the human race
to the greater good right i think the
thing but it's and it's
a selfish it actually becomes a selfish
perception and i just
in that podcast i demonstrated how
that can happen with something so
unimportant as me thinking that you're
competitive like
you know what if it was having an
argument about abortion
you know for god's sake right right but
no i wasn't even talking about something
that has any emotional weight to it i
was just talking about
whether or not you're competitive it
came from a conversation about board
games but yet
even then i was willing to and i was a
very willing participant
in identifying with that position and
once i threw it out there and it
encountered some resistant energy i
energized the side of my conversation
to try to get my energy to beat your
energy so i could be like my energy wins
and i won this argument and i just feel
like that
negative energy that's happening on both
sides
it's happening on both sides of the
spectrum at this point
um is like there's just something that's
been lost
and i'm a part of it i'm i'm saying that
i am a part of it
but i'm realizing that i i want to be a
part of the solution and not just
contribute to the noise
i don't really know what that looks like
i don't have any application
um you know
and i i and i'm and ultimately i'm not
encouraged so i'm not
i'm not going to end it on a happy note
for me personally i'm encouraged with
some of the things that
have happened and that being one of the
things is like oh man
you tend to be you tend to be um
you know you tend to want to debate or
argue or you you want to be right
and that's not about that's not about
being wanting to people to understand
the truth as much as it's about
you wanting to be right your ego that's
it i'm glad that i'm beginning to
realize that
but the thing that is is is discouraging
is um our interconnectedness that we've
been able to achieve
given the proliferation of the internet
um has backfired
and we're way less connected i think
than we've ever been
and it does not seem to be
there doesn't seem to be any sort of
resolution in sight
and instead of you know instead of
commenting on that i'll i'll take it
aside and just say
if since this is the time where we're
talking about if this is the follow-up
to the
competition i'll just give the like the
concise way that i've processed it i
think
for me uh i didn't read a lot of the
comments
you know um uh
i had discussions with you know with
christy
um i might have had a therapy discussion
about it i may not have
yeah but you know uh one of the things
that
kind of when i look back on the
conversation now
is uh the thing that i carry with me
is i realized that it was
you know it didn't unpacking
like the com the competitive your
competitive nature
you know i i very much internalize that
as kind of a
as a threat right um
and then what i what i
what i did part of my process was kind
of coming through that saying you know
what
analyzing that but then also realizing
that if the thing that sticks with me
the positive thing from the conversation
is that if
if there's a competitive spirit
between us and it doesn't just go one
way and i'm not denying that
like they're i'm not saying i'm not
competitive at all
but i am asserting that i am not the
same i'm not
i'm not the same as you in this way uh
that i think what i it kind of
it kind of hurt because i felt
threatened by it
the turn was actually being honored by
it
like if you you know you're not
competitive with everybody if you
if there is a competitive spirit from
you towards me
then i can take i honestly take that as
a compliment
you know that that is a level of respect
that uh i didn't immediately
experience but the more i thought about
it and reflected on it i was like
that's that's my takeaway from it so
it's you know i take it as a compliment
okay good and uh
yeah i i do find it fascinating that
because there's mics in front of us it
does it
changes the dynamic of the conversation
a little bit but the conversation that
we had
afterward for the next two hours
i you know there was a lot of good that
came from that too that
you know didn't need to be on mike and i
think it was
uh it was a it was a it was a milestone
moment yeah i think and a good thing i'm
glad we had the conversation yeah
um i just have come to grips with
why i pushed things the way that i did
and some people were really you know
some people were really
really picked up on that um and
ironically
or i guess not so ironically but
fittingly
um even my competitive nature in a lot
of ways is
based in the way that in the way that
how i identify what i identify with and
what i find my worth in right and
a lot of times i find my worth in
winning at things
and again that's just another
displacement
of my identity into this performance
meeting some expectation whether it's
set by me or set by somebody else
um so even the argument that i was
having
was trying to get you to realize that
you think about this in the same way
that i do
that the thing i was trying to get you
to think about was also a symptom of my
ego
and the way i was doing it it was a
symptom of my ego
um and none of this is like super
revolutionary it's like
it isn't like if you had told me that
before that conversation
i probably would have been like yeah
that's true wanting to be right and
wanting to have an argument and kind of
digging into your trench in an argument
is based in ego but i didn't i don't
felt i don't feel like i had a um
to get back what we're talking about an
experiential heart knowledge or an ex
i could agree with it intellectually
yeah yeah but now i'm like oh i can
feel that and i think
i have just a little bit
more um sort of
consciousness of that tendency
so when i when i go there when i find
myself going there when i'm in
and when i find myself suddenly in an
argument being like whoa
whoa whoa has this has this suddenly
shifted
do you care anymore about whether or not
what the truth is
or do you just care about being right
because it feels like
our culture has gotten to a place where
uh
the only thing anyone cares about is
just being right
well i i think that what you're
describing you're
sharing your experience is is is a
source of hope
you know at least we got this one data
point
you know and i you know i want to be
that person too that's like
i'm not going to hold on to something so
tightly that i lose myself
who i really want to be and i think
so i understand why you're saying it's
like i'm not really in it on a hopeful
note but at the same time i
i think i think that there's a hopeful
takeaway
well i hope so uh okay well we should go
you know i'm saying we should we should
make sure we pick dates
and that we go off again well and that
and that's my
that's my recommendation it's very
simple it's very general um
make time for yourself we did the whole
chapter and
isolate yourself with yourself yeah and
you know it's
it's something that i um
knew is important the you know my
therapist is telling me you
need this i'm believing that i need this
but it took me i mean i did my little
trip
to the place with the yoga thing in the
hot tub that you know a couple years ago
but it was different it felt different
yeah um
but just making that time for yourself
you may not be in a position especially
given the circumstances in the world to
travel right now
but like there's just something about
giving yourself some space releasing
yourself
of expectations responsibilities
the need to accomplish something and
just letting yourself off the hook
um and really spending some time
just discovering yourself and for me it
was helpful
to to get away and also to read a few
books that
had been recommended to me which again
i'm not going to recommend those books i
don't you don't have to read what i read
it's just that was for me
but um yeah make some time for yourself
isolate yourself with yourself that's my
wreck
hashtag your biscuits let us know we'll
speak at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left
and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best